now 2016 looks set to be a big one for
Scottish politics the Hollywood
elections in May of course will show
just how far the SNP has cemented its
position and support and will be one of
the first key tests of whether labor
under Jeremy Corbyn can win back the
votes it lost to the SNP last year while
I'm joined now by Scotland's Deputy
First Minister John Swinney he's in
black Gary in Persia and a very good
morning to you mr. Sweeny let's talk
flooding of course in everyone's mind
and we know more bad weather forecasts
for for Scotland in other areas and
according to your opponents you failed
to keep your eye on the ball in your
recent budget you what you've cut the
Scottish Environmental Protection
Agency's budget by six percent now in
the front line of dealing with flooding
well the Scots Environmental Protection
Agency of course has a broad range of
responsibilities and what the budget
settlement provides for is sustained
funding for the flood forecasting
service for example and also for the
investment that's necessary in a variety
of flood protection and flood
alleviation schemes which we've
sustained since we came to office in
2007 in which we intend to sustain for
the duration of this budget settlement
so we've got a lot of work that's being
done just now to protect communities
from the harsh effects of flooding I was
up in Balaton on Thursday to see it
firsthand the very acute difficulties
that have been experienced in the First
Minister we're still in the southwest of
Scotland and flooding and the
implications of flooding are very
serious for individuals and the
government is committed to doing all
that we can to support communities and
withstanding these challenges by going
to visit them but not spending enough
money on the flood defences so you froze
the cash available for flooding in 1617
2016-17 at 9 point 1 million shouldn't
you increased it well what we've done is
we've put in place capital funding for
flood prevention schemes which is by
agreement with our local authority
partners and we take forward a range of
schemes we've taken forward schemes in
Edinburgh and Elgin in Selkirk and
Galashiels
right across the length and breadth of
Scotland over the last six last nine
years
and we will of course take forward a
variety of other schemes that I brought
forward as a
consequence of the spending load in
which we become involved and what we
what we do and what we work with our
local authority partners to do is to
make sure that all of the preventative
activity that we can undertake is put in
place to support communities in
establishing and what's more resilient
approach to dealing with flooding and to
ensure that we support communities where
these very harsh effects teeth of course
that we recover as quickly as we
possibly can do okay
let's move on to the issue of the
Hollywood elections then do you detect
and labor sources is telling if they do
will you deny it that those labor
supporters who voted for the SNP in the
general election may well return to the
party now Jeremy Corbyn is in charge
there's not really any evidence of that
in Scotland the opinion polls are still
very strong for the Scottish National
Party there was one just before the new
year which had our support at in excess
of 50% for both the constituency and the
regional parliamentary election results
and these are these are of course from
the opinion polls but they are an
indication of the strong support that
the Scottish National Party still enjoys
and when you add to that the variety of
local authority by-elections that have
taken place over the course of the last
few months we've seen the levels of
support that we gained in the general
election back in me
being continued to be delivered so these
are all indications of the strength of
support that exists for the Scottish
National Party but we take none of that
support for granted we work very hard
and our candidates around the country
our campaign teams around the country
will work very hard over the course of
the next few months to engage directly
with voters to say to the strength of
the record of the SNP government to make
the approach and to set out the approach
that we would take if we were fortunate
enough to secure a mandate in the
elections in me and of course set out
the challenges that First Minister
Nicola Sturgeon wants to take forward it
should she be reelected as the First
Minister of Scotland and me so we've got
a strong record to campaign on we've got
a forward agenda and ambitious agenda
for Scotland and we'll take that to the
people well people will just be
interested now of course on the issue of
another independent
referendum what you will set out in that
manifesto for the Scottish elections
about some what you would regard
specifically as the trigger from a
negative result overall in the United
Kingdom for remaining a member of the
European Union what you would then
regard as a trigger then for another
referendum on Scottish independence
we've said two things about the question
of a second referendum the fastest that
clearly a UK exit against the wishes of
the people of Scotland from the European
Union and would really be a very serious
change in the proposition that was put
to people in the referendum by the new
campaign it was one of the strongest
arguments the No campaign advanced which
was the only way you could guarantee you
riu membership was to vote no and of
course we might find ourselves against
our wishes facing exactly that scenario
so that would be a very significant
change of circumstances but the second
thing we've said is that there would
have to be a discernible and sustained
increase in support for independence as
a consequence of the change in attitudes
within Scotland at the referendum we
secured a very strong level of support
for independence at 45 percent it was
much higher than anybody anticipated
that much higher than our opponents were
trying to see levels of support for
independence achieving but it wasn't
enough and we have to recognize that
people have to change their opinions
they have to change their mind
substantially before Scotland could
become an independent country so but
we'll flesh out in more detail in our
manifesto exactly about the
circumstances and the details would be
around about that but we have to be
mindful of those 2 kasa durations I just
want to squeeze the last question into
mr. Sweeny but a savvy SNP voter would
listen to that and say well hold on a
minute is mr. Sweeney telling me to
although I would do want to stay in the
European Union if I want another
referendum as quickly as possible it
might be in my interest to vote
tactically in the EU referendum and vote
no well they sent people
enthusiastically and energetically
campaigned for the United Kingdom to
remain part of the European Union we
believe that to be the right thing for
Scotland and the right thing for the
European Union so noise and people to
know
of any political party will be in any
doubt that the SNP is absolutely
committed to EU membership and will work
very hard to make sure that's the case
okay John Swinney thank you very much in
the Deputy First Minister